imágenes de hace 20 años que pasaron a
la historia después de este anuncio del
entonces presidente de Estados Unidos
George Bush en este momento las fuerzas
estadounidenses y de la coalición se
encuentran en las primeras fases de las
operaciones militares para desarmar Irak
liberar su pueblo y defender el mundo de
un grave peligro una invasión que dio
inicio una cruenta guerra en el país que
se extendió hasta 2011 y se saltó con la
vida de cientos de miles de civiles pero
Cuáles son los principales actores
armados Estados Unidos y la coalición
grupo de países que apoyaron en
militarmente o políticamente la invasión
fueron uno de los principales actores
Durante los ocho años que estuvieron en
el país derrocaron al gobierno de Sadam
hussein pusieron a un ejecutivo Chita
Aliado en el poder y fueron acusados de
crímenes de guerra y violaciones a los
Derechos Humanos el gobierno era aquí
combatió a Los Invasores pero atrás del
derrocamiento de hussein Estados lo
desmantelo por ser de mayoría sunita y
colocó a soldados citas Con escasa
preparación y malos resultados un batido
frente al que surgieron las milicias
iraquíes para plantarle cara a la
coalición en especial destaca el
conocido como ejército de almagí que
comparó a Estados Unidos con una
serpiente y mató a muchos de sus
soldados en 2004 los grupos terroristas
también han desempeñado un rol central
en el conflicto desde al qaeda hasta la
autodenominado estado islámico nacido en
Irak y derivado de la corriente sunita
fundamentalista ambas formaciones
consideraban al régimen exita iraquí
como ilegítimo y querían devolver al
poder a los sunitas con La retirada de
Estados Unidos del país en 2011
aprovecharon el vacío de poder y Se
tomaron un tercio del país también hay
un espacio reservado para los
patchmergas o kurdos históricamente han
reivindicado tierras del Norte del país
causando con el gobierno iraquí por lo
que se aliaron con Estados Unidos y
occidente y tuvieron un papel a
fundamental en la caída de husein aunque
aún no han conseguido la tan anhelada
Independencia 20 años después con el
conflicto supuestamente atrás aún hay
grupos armados que generan gran
inestabilidad en Irak tanto es así que
en 2014 el presidente Obama tuvo que
enviar a 2500 tropas para asistir al
ejecutivo iraquí que aún siguen allí con
la promesa de estabilidad muy lejos en
el horizonte